[Music]
what's up guys
jared again media has a huge effect on
the way we view the world
jaws made everyone afraid of sharks it
made everyone afraid of clowns
big made everybody afraid of being
rapidly aged by a weird fortune telling
machine
but what about when media actually
portrays the real world in all of its
whale abusers duck hunters and baby
beauty queens
if imaginary house elves can make us
more sympathetic to inequality
what does watching actual factual humans
do to us
we're in the midst of a non-fiction
media boom both documentary and reality
tv
there were 750 reality shows in 2015
leading some critics to say that it's
even remade television culture
entirely similarly documentary has been
cinema's unlikely cinderella in recent
years
with three documentaries in 2018
cracking the list of
top 30 highest grossing documentaries
since 1982
and that's not even counting the insane
proliferation of documentary filmmaking
happening on streaming sites
if fictional media changes the way we
view the world how does non-fiction
media contribute to
or inform our world view in short what
might documentaries and reality tv
be doing to our brainy parts let's find
out in this week's wisecrack edition on
the philosophy of documentaries and
reality tv
and spoilers ahead for some
documentaries to figure out how
documentaries and reality tv
affect us we first need to understand
what this stuff is
documenting reality is literally as old
as filmmaking itself
the earliest films made around the end
of the 19th century were pretty much
all super short visual accounts of real
life events
like workers piecing out from their
factory or an elephant being cruelly
tortured for our entertainment
which you can thank your favorite light
bulb inventing scoundrel thomas edison
for
yes this elephant is about to be
electrocuted and no we're not going to
show you cause
but the term documentary has always
implied more than just taking a camera
and shooting whatever goes down in the
life of your local yodeling community
though by all means go for it the word
documentary was first used by scottish
filmmaker john grierson in the 1920s
and he described it as the creative
treatment of actuality
even this definition says a lot applying
creativity to actuality
already suggests that it's distinct from
actual actuality
rather than showing neutral uncut
footage of an event a documentarian will
use a variety of tools
including editing to string together a
compelling story
since its early days documentary has had
a complicated relationship with the
truth
take the 1922 documentary nanook of the
north which depicted the life of a man
from the enoch tribe
the film is definitely misleading for
starters nanuk wasn't even named nanuk
his real name was alec hagialak but the
director robert j flaherty thought that
was unmarketable
flaherty also staged several scenes
which were historically inaccurate
showing enoch life the way it would have
been a century prior
for instance though nanook typically
hunted walruses with a simple gun
flaherty asked him to use a harpoon for
the sake of drama
the film's various elements compound to
present nanook and his family as
childish primitive and a bit silly it
helps here to think of a different
definition of documentary
as an imaginative representation of an
actual
historical reality documentary is
supposed to have fidelity to a
particular historical reality
whether it's showing an enoch tribe in
the 1920s or a wealthy florida housewife
in 2012
flaherty distorted that reality by
depicting historically inaccurate
customs
as we move forward to the 1930s and 40s
the way documentary bends the truth is
perhaps most glaringly apparent
when just about every major country put
out its own form of propaganda
trying to get people jazzed about war
and whatnot most notably triumph of the
will solidified hitler's power and
public persona
now we seem to talk about this movie
more often than a 1930s german soldier
in a dive bar but i swear
it's relevant in this film we see the
way subtle choices in cinematography can
drastically alter a documentary's
meaning
and fidelity to the truth look at the
way hitler appears on camera
from a low angle shot he seems taller
almost larger than life
and certainly more powerful gross anyway
that same year the talking head or the
interview style in which an often boring
person stares at the screen and talks
for a while
would be introduced via the documentary
housing problems as an attempt to let
individuals tell their own story
rather than having it dictated by a
voice of god narrator
this was an honest attempt to make
storytelling more truthful
in the 1960s cameras became smaller
allowing film crews to become more
mobile
this facilitated a new form of
documentary practice by filmmakers like
the mazel's brothers
it was called cinema verite which
translates to truthful cinema or
cinema of truth functionally cinema
verite filmmakers will follow their
subject around
passively observing their lives without
interfering as the subject ignores the
camera
all in an attempt to more accurately
capture the truth
of course that caused problems of its
own because the camera movements
imply honesty we assume that we're
watching actual reality
some filmmakers such as richard
pennebaker who made the bob dylan
documentary don't look back
were sensitive to this and purposely
kept aesthetically unpleasing
cinematography flourishes
to argue for the film's truthfulness
showing the audience the camera eye
focusing or keeping
awkward zooms filmmakers began
experimenting further with the very
nature of what it meant to engage in
non-fiction storytelling
documentarian errol morris incorporated
dramatic reenactments to simulate a
real-life
murder in his 1988 film the thin blue
line
to some criticism by the early 90s more
intimate documentaries became popular
functioning as cinematic autobiographies
or a close look at an artist's family
in recent years films also became
voicier as in the work of michael moore
who editorializes and inserts himself
into his own plots
less documenting reality than crafting
it
the 2000s were dominated by
documentaries that made strong
arguments like an inconvenient truth
supersize me
and fahrenheit 911. in supersize me the
documentarian is the opposite of the
neutral observer
he literally turns the camera on himself
and his rapidly deteriorating liver
which if we're speaking about ethics
becomes a little more problematic due to
recent revelations that director morgan
spurlock was a longtime alcoholic
so can we really blame only the fast
food in a lot of ways
these films are more self-aware than
your classic cinema verite
their artifice is right on the surface
for example when michael moore storms a
general motors shareholders meeting
we clearly know we're not witnessing
neutral reality
at the same time modern filmmakers are
also arguably
taking more creative license with the
truth there is perhaps no greater
narrative artifice than the satisfying
climactic
ending many a documentarian has grappled
with this but perhaps none more
interestingly
than filmmaker ben berman in his
documentary the untitled amazing
jonathan documentary
in it the filmmaker shadows the titular
terminally ill magician
the problem is several other people are
doing the exact same thing
looking for a way to make his story
stand out berman at one point believes
that the only satisfying conclusion
would be jonathan
dying waiting for your subject to die is
pretty blatantly macabre
and jonathan even calls the guy out on
it you're just waiting you're just
waiting you're
fighting your time till i die and then
you get that ending you want here berman
confronts the inherent ethical dilemmas
of imposing requirements of a satisfying
story
on reality luckily he finds an ending
without
killing the amazing jonathan but beyond
imposing artificial beginnings and ends
creatively tinkering with reality has
other complications
take the issue of characterization or
the way that characters are constructed
in a given piece of media
scholar carl plantinga notes that in any
documentary
the images and sounds that represent the
character are not
neutral and transparent but carefully
constructed
and chosen to portray them in a specific
way
he adds that the process of selection
and omission
emphasis plotting and point of view all
create additional ethical dilemmas for
documentarians
the way most documentarians will deal
with this is to make characters that
are as plantinga puts it flat or simple
possessing one or two central
characteristics
for example in a michael moore
documentary like roger and me
which serves as an indictment of the
very very wealthy you're not gonna see
general motors ceo roger smith patting
his son on the back
or giving a dollar to a homeless man
because the message of the film is that
he's an
evil outpour forming round or complex
characters according to plantinga
is much more difficult and so for the
most part every aspect of filmmaking and
editing
will serve to emphasize a central
quality of any given character
now this is also true of fiction that's
part of what makes it fiction
flat character seems like as good a
segue to reality tv
as we could ask for now reality tv has
always been documentaries bastard son
but we just want to say here most
documentarians struggle
deeply with the ethics of their craft
reality tv
not so much it's less respected and
taken less seriously
it's also frequently charged with taking
a giant nerf gun to reality
but the truth is more complicated some
of the earliest iterations of televisual
reality fall
somewhere between the categories of
documentary and reality tv
this includes candid camera which used a
hidden camera to film normal people
reacting to practical jokes
on and off from 1948 to 2014.
similarly an american family used what
television scholar misha kovka calls a
live-in camera to chronicle the
oftentimes boring pursuits of one upper
middle class american family to the
delight of millions kafka goes on to
separate the history of
real reality tv into three distinct
categories
the first is the camcorder generation
which hit a stride in 1989 with a boom
of crime and emergency programs
that offer an ultra verite experience
through the use of shaky ride along
footage
these shows were super real but they
also vacillated between
being very exciting and very very boring
so reality tv regrouped the second
generation began in 1999 and that's when
things get
gnarly we start seeing competition shows
like survivor
the amazing race american idol and
america's next top model
along with surveillance shows like big
brother and the real world
as kovka notes the genre began
developing its own
format rules production practices and
audience expectations
such as confessional interviews
elimination ceremonies and
plenty of ugly crying kavka notes that
this era of reality tv found its place
in the millennial culture imaginary
by openly combining actuality and
artifice
in ways that broke ratings records and
caused wide scale debate
intriguingly enough every 22-minute
episode of the real world
was the result of 70 hours worth of raw
footage
meaning this version of reality is has
to be
cherry picked and skewed these shows
frequently insert their casts into
artificially constructed situations that
generate
lots of stress then they actively
facilitate the social destruction that
follows
often by staging and producing scenes
that complete the narrative arc
also booze not exactly the kind of
things the maisel's brothers would have
been about
the third era of reality tv kind of
crept up starting in 2002 with what
kafka describes as a
gradual but noticeable change from an
emphasis on documenting ordinary life
to manufacturing celebrity out of the
everyday
the very phrase manufacturing celebrity
not so subtly hints at the artifice
inherent in these shows
where characters seek the insubstantial
but highly desirable commodity called
fame people's on-screen behavior is
increasingly motivated less by
genuine emotions than by the desire to
attract as much attention as possible
a phenomenon best encapsulated by kris
jenner who could turn
a bunion on kim's big toe into an
international news story
and probably already has what we're
seeing is that
far more so than documentary reality tv
involves
deliberate departures from truth be it
in the form of hawkeye producers staging
dramatic scenes
or a drunk housewife doing it herself in
hopes of scoring her own vodka brand
if the second generation of reality tv
birthed several distinctive genre tools
the third generation solidified them as
a result
certain aspects of reality tv are so
familiar to us
from the tearful confession of past
trauma to the manufactured fights
to the words you're going home so what
is the net result of watching tv and
movies that are optimized and dramatized
but self present to the audience
as real one consequence that really
resonates with us is that documentaries
and reality tv
make us narrativize reality that is
see our own lives and the lives of those
around us
as stories with beginnings middles and
ends
as philosopher alex rosenberg puts it in
his book how history gets things wrong
we humans have an insatiable appetite
for stories with identifiable heroes
the tension of a quest obstacles
overcome and a happy
or at least emotionally satisfying
ending quick note
though rosenberg is talking more broadly
about the way we employ historical
narratives we think it could be usefully
applied to documentary and reality tv as
forms of entertainment
rosenberg also notes that we use
historical narratives to make sense of
the present
and even predict the future we may watch
a makeover show and think our lives are
just
one overnight transformation away from
fulfillment
and how could watching hours of banal
kardashian drama
not make us think that maybe just maybe
our lives might be interesting enough to
be chronicled for the world to
snarkily enjoy what's more rosenberg
argues stories with
satisfying narratives are like aloe vera
for our brains
soothing us and lulling us into a false
sense of understanding
susan boyle may have never been kissed
but boy did she wow the judges on
britain's got talent
here susan's real-life suffering is
first used to make us care about her
moment 11 million is my cat called
pebbles i've never been married
never been kissed then her objectively
excellent performance and rousing
reception
offer a compelling resolution that
ultimately redeems her
and her suffering
[Music]
it wasn't for nothing after all or even
if we're healthily skeptical of a
chopped narrative
i just feel like people find reasons to
hate on me because i'm
definitely different some part of us is
stoked that this girl suffering at the
hands of bullies
has been redeemed by winning chopped
junior
all of this fundamentally limits our
understanding of the world
as scholar ibanda biergreit summarizing
the work of neurologist antonio damasio
our sense of self and our ability to
interpret the world
are based on emotional and narrative
structures narrative structures are part
of the very
fabric of our mind and imagination so
our brains crave narrative like a
unicorn craves sparkles
and reality tv sells us that narrative
as truth
as a result watching the voice may
subtly make us think that everything we
do in life can be seen as us
triumphing over our central life
struggle watching the bachelor subtly
makes us eager to find our happily ever
after
a term that is certainly ridiculous to
anyone who's ever been married
i don't know what turns me on more that
sexy failure talk
or the bologna shrapnel hit me in the
eye
and watching my super sweet 16 not so
subtly informs us that absurdly wealthy
adolescents are
monsters which no comment
this can be a problem because real life
isn't made up of neat narrative arcs
and clean happy endings it's messy and
things happen for no reason
and not every choice you make is
motivated by the fact that the
neighborhood apple ricky made you wear
your underwear as a hat in the third
grade
you probably won't have a hero's journey
and if you do
it probably won't take place in three
acts but
watching enough nonfiction media has a
tendency to confuse us
so what is a responsible non-masochistic
movie watcher supposed to do with all
this information
should you protest chop's false
narrativizing or skip that super
compelling documentary on kim jong-il
impersonators
which doesn't exist but god damn it
should we love documentaries just as
much as the next film nerd and we'd
never ruin the great british bake off
for you
we just feel like as media fanatics we
should all be a little bit more aware of
the way everyday storytelling affects
the way we view our own lives
and our own stories but what do you guys
think
are documentaries and reality tv ruining
the way you understand the world
or is narrativizing reality just a
necessary part of being human
[Music]
so
you